so it's official Dark Souls 2 has a
release date March 2014 but before I
talk about this I want to talk about
that concept art in the background if
you want to skip to the discussion about
the release date click the annotation on
the screen so this is art done by Crom
zhang a Chinese concept artist last year
he joined the Dark Souls 2 project as a
part-time concept artist we know this
because he created the first design of
the protagonist which was adapted and
remade by from the required theme for
this piece was described as a knight
standing in a snow field
so recently we became aware of his
angles broader artwork in portfolio
since we know he's working on Dark Souls
2 it's fair to say that some of these
pieces are related to the game I'd be
happy to see even a few of them get
through just look at how great some of
these environments look but they could
also be examples of his other work so
while I show these bear in mind that
while we can be fairly certain that from
will draw inspiration from them that's
also impossible to say for sure whether
they'll use all of them whether they'll
use any of them or how they'll build
upon that foundation but man what a
foundation that would be so anyway onto
the release date March 2014 now I know
what you're thinking that's a long way
away but isn't that a good thing I mean
most importantly this release date means
that the game won't be rushed we know
for a fact that the developers weren't
happy with a lot of things in Dark Souls
and they admitted that a lot of content
was cut in order to ship the game in
time we've known for a quite a while
that the team wasn't keen to make that
mistake again
but even so I don't think many people
were expecting a release quite that late
personally I'm thrilled with the date in
terms of the game quality the longer the
development the better I mean we play
these games for years after their
release we're not one of those
communities that gets a yearly
installment to keep things fresh so
wouldn't you rather they develop an
amazing game to keep us entertained
longer I mean look at you guys we're
still you're still watching lore videos
and discussion about a game that was
released a year and a half ago we need a
game that can survive the long term so
I'm happy to wait
as a final note on the release date
it'll be interesting to see what they
decide to do in terms of next-gen
consoles as of this date the video was
posted Dark Souls 2 is slated for
release on xbox 360 ps3 and pc
developers have come out and said that
they will not be targeting next-gen
consoles so is it smart to have a
release date for current gen systems
six months into the release of next-gen
systems it's probably not a terrible
idea you have to remember that even by
March 2014 the install base for one and
ps4 will be tiny compared to the 360 and
ps3 and from an Namco might not be
interested in next-gen consoles now but
I guarantee no guarantee but I bet
they'll port the game over eventually
another reason I say this is because
next-gen console architecture is closer
to PC than anything else before
considering the game is being built for
PC from the ground up I reckon it's
pretty likely that they'll ported over
but what do you think do you think it's
smart to release six months into the
next-gen let me know